this is kind of a thing that Americans
are obsessed with right now but as
someone who's from India and and and
spent much of your life living working
in another country what's your take on
Trump what's your feeling about him oh
I'm not gonna lie
okay I'm gonna lie no I think if
anything and and you always want to be
complimentary in another person's
country so if anything I can say because
you can sense the discomfort in the
audience right he's very entertaining
yes he is
you know like what I like to do is you
know they said that if you listen to
stairway to heaven and and play Wizard
of Oz on TV it matches up it syncs up
you're watching Wizard of Oz I've heard
this if you watch them is I've never
done it but if you watch Wizard of Oz
and you play and you start that dark
side of the dark side of the Dark Side
of the Moon at the same time it actually
all fits together beautiful I do that
with Trump's tweets and Bohemian
Rhapsody like I'll put on the evil
section of Bohemian Rhapsody and like
start reading Trump's tweets because I
don't know what's happening in the White
House at 3 o'clock in the morning but in
my mind it's like this greco-roman orgy
that's happening and he's tweeting in
the middle of it and in which part of
Bohemian Rhapsody just a big operatic
part yeah like I think it starts out
with him just sitting in the White House
and he's all sad and he's alone he's
like nothing really matters nothing
really matters Timmy
and then somebody hands the president of
phone and he starts to tweet
I didn't even people just come out of
the woodwork and like I see your little
smartphone in his head what the deuce
what a douche he will type the creepy
lingo spelling while he's typing very
very frightening
[Applause]
though climate change as a whole to me
love see you know then the party start
and then he it said hey I think if
you're living in another country you get
drop in on Trump
you know we're with us it's a 24-7
culture I think that where's this we may
find it less entertaining because I
think if you're living another country
you can be thinking about what's going
on with you and then you can drop in and
say what's up with Trump like you're
checking in on a show well I feel like
look you're a country that has driven
the world's moral compass for a very
very long time you've done more for
gender rights and race relations in the
environment ahead of the rest of the
world I think you've earned yourself a
stumble a little bit you know you've
done so much in showing the world where
to go this is just a small stumble and
you get back up and you show the world
where to go from this point on again I
think that's
[Applause]